foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
stop thinking you've got to be kidding
me
it's strong with this one
she's a lion a tiger
you're embarrassing me
it takes the lessons keeping it cool for
all the cats
I'm a bad dog
a Samurai and training who doesn't have
his moves and grooves yet
but this pup won't duck out even when
Danger's all about running around like
he's got nine lives and living them all
at the same time you feel me
who's the baddest fattest cat of them
all Jimbo
keep your eye on this Samurai but don't
get too close cause he's the teacher
that don't want to meet you hold this
[Applause]
he's busy learning this fool how to
slice and dice his way through life but
the mother father cocker spaniels going
on here
foreign
did not see that coming
pussycat is a real teddy bear
ah meets Pikachu
Ika you know who me
he's lean and he's mean how's everyone
doing feeding evil a funkified fancy
pants furball who's about to meet a
legend stop stop I am your father
they're not no I'm not
he's the villain who's stealing I'm
still it and willing to do anything to
stop Our Heroes now get out
foreign
why do you want to be a samurai
I lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
the samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor
so once great Samurai who has fallen on
hard times and maybe could use some help
himself
go find one
get out of here who even made that it's
you don't believe everything you read
[Music]
you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
go get them
oh
get back out there
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it
[Applause]
don't forget to land on your
feet
[Music]
I wanna see gonna move
we've gotta wipe that town off the map
send a tweet to assemble the troops
an evil Army could go through so many
beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] cocker spaniels
going on here
the legend of Hank time to finish this
ah
this might take a while
[Music]